so a year on from the last cop let's see
how a few numbers have shifted in 12
months actual Global temperature has
increased by
0.024 degrees at the top here is the
past week's power mix but let's compare
September last year to September this
year in a slightly different form this
radar chart it shows that the proportion
of wind in the UK's electricity mix
jumped from 18 last September to 24 this
September and this Gusty November a
record's already been set the first time
wind has generated over 20 gigawatts of
electricity on a single day more than
half of our total electricity demand but
despite these achievements and world
leaders meeting in Egypt greenhouse
gases of course continue to build and
scientists are worried that this could
trigger some massive changes to our
natural world well Thomas Moore is here
to talk about this our science
correspondent Thomas is this all about
tipping points yes and they are adding
to the urgency of the talks in Egypt
because these tipping points are really
big changes to the Earth Systems you
could say life support systems because
they are so critical to moving
temperatures in the climate around the
world but the point is that once they
start they can't be stopped and they
could potentially be catastrophic sound
like a very big deal what kind of things
are we talking about yeah so we can look
at some of them so go up to the top of
the world and you've got the Greenland
ice sheet now that's two miles thick at
its uh Summit and as that ice is melting
it's coming into contact with warmer Air
at lower altitude speeding up the Melt
now if that all goes that adds seven and
a half meters to Global sea levels wow
that's taller than an average house yeah
and it gets worse because if you go to
the South you've got the West Antarctic
ice sheet now that's a series of glasses
and if one collapses then there's going
to be a domino effect if they all go
that's another three meters being added
to Global sea levels up to the top of
the world again and you've got Arctic
permafrost another of the likely ones to
to reach a Tipping Point that is a
frozen Earth which loops around the
Arctic and it contains one and a half
trillion tons of carbon historic uh
prehistoric uh animals and plants which
haven't rotted down but as microbes wake
up that's starting to happen it could be
a carbon bomb which then accelerates
climate change and then you've got uh
coral reefs in tropical Seas now 99 of
those could go and these are living life
forms and they are stressed by warm
water normally recover but the water is
now so warm that they could die now
coral reefs support fish that feed a
billion people so really important now
are these kind of immediate things or
are they a bit you know like a Hollywood
movie or are they a bit longer term many
people misunderstand what a Tipping
Point is it's not going to happen like a
Hollywood movie where it happens in a
matter of days this is something that
could happen over centuries but the
point is it's a juggernaut you can't
stop and the four that I've mentioned
there those happen at one and a half
degrees we're currently on course for
two and a half degrees of global warming
then you're going to see the loss of
Arctic sea ice the loss of mountain
glaciers and the disruption to the West
Africa Monsoon it just gets worse and
that's why Egypt is so important and the
big threat here is that they are
irreversible once they start indeed
Thomas thank you very much and indeed